wenn ich du wäre würde ich einfach mal
unsere koordinaten in den chat schreiben
ein gegner ist es darum das spiel zu
verlassen das tut er ruft mich denn
jetzt an max hallo herr luca was geht
was geht heißt es wichtig ja wohl heute
abend ist es heute abend ja ich denke
mal du bist genau so gut vorbereitet wie
ich ja ich hatte gerade eigentlich noch
zu tun fünf minuten vorher aber kann ich
auch nachher machen was gibt wer süßes
an also weißt du was du willst etwas los
wir sind beide nicht mehr so die die die
größten prozent minecraft was müssen wir
unseren zuschauern bieten und ich habe
mir da so ein paar gedanken gemacht was
hast du dir dann da überlegt was wir
machen können was hältst du von der idee
dass wir jede einzelne ware folge eine
andere stelle machen wie meinst du dass
jede einzelne folge machen wie irgendwas
anderes gegenseitig sage ich mal genau
um das ganze aber ein bisschen
aufzupeppen weil wir wahrscheinlich
skill mäßig nicht so bei den top ten
sind wie zum beispiel jetzt in der
ersten folge wenn ich du wäre oder sowas
dass das ganze ein bisschen du willst
jetzt in der ersten folge wenn ich du
wäre challenge machen ja safe oder
meinst du das ist so groß für die erste
folge also ich bin dabei ich würde sagen
dann sehen wir uns jetzt eben game
wieder und dann machen wir das ja auch
hierzu okay was mir spaß wir sind jetzt
hingehen meine damen und herren wir
beginnen zehn sekunden ok luca wie
besprochen und blogger frauen ab in den
weiteren ich glaub dir hinterher direkt
bei mir hinterher gamers teams hinter
uns
echt neben dir quasi okay dann bauen wie
direct holz abholzen holzabbau gab es
keine gute idee direkt holte abzubauen
oder doch baum kräftigen table lucassen
schnell du kannst dabei und stellen den
ställen stehen hin anspannung vor meine
damen und herren
okay da wird man merkt dass ich länger
nicht
minecraft gespielt haben ja schon schwer
und jetzt vorsichtig - liegen wir
brauchen essen am anfang mal okay die
werbe anspannung ist da leute anspricht
hat die kommt nicht mehr gerade aber
okay wir laufen jetzt wissen und gehen
einfach über die bäume wachsen wenn ich
du wäre für dich kurz den deutschen ist
das laut junge sollten wir folgen den
folgen wie folgt mir luca du bist du dir
okay ich hätte gegen jetzt ruht aber
vorsichtig
vorsichtig vorsichtig vorsichtig wir
brauchen nämlich am anfang auf jeden
fall essen
wo bist du es nicht guckt aber nach
meinem namen
da bist du okay okay okay so folgten mal
laufen hinterher
vorbei und vergessen nicht wir gehen
wieder auf die bäume braucht eine
bessere übersicht sind die blitze wäre
ja auch so laut wie das kannst du gleich
ändern noch aber erstmal dass wir leute
tut mir leid
mag es wenn nicht wäre würde ich zehn
liegestütze machen
gerade jetzt brauchen die gestützten
junge wir sind noch direkter nähe von
jaja gaal mache jetzt zehn liegestütze
du kannst nicht okay doch ich mache
jetzt ganz schnell leute das ist nämlich
unsere bahro taktik wir machen
challenges direkt während der hort mein
gott da ist ein mädchen mag sich dass
das mädchen riecht als arschloch
okay okay ich lebe habe ich neben vor
luca aller art ich habe angst gehabt
gerade okay ich werde euch jetzt mal
hast du dich dabei gefilmt wie du dich
dabei gefilmt okay ich bin ich jetzt mal
kurz einig dass bei max aussagt
ich werde dich ich werde hier so
zurückgeben
es ist okay wenn unten folgen wir folgen
ihm folgt mir ja okay dass ein hase hat
lasst uns mal unter die erde gehen oder
so ja wir brauchen noch ein bisschen
holz auf jeden fall dass man machen
[Musik]
wir bräuchten vielleicht mal ein stein
steht erstmal auf jeden fall ein
bisschen holz lassen wir unter die erde
gehen ja ein bisschen angst unter der
erde hier gerade da kommen wir suchen
uns eine höhle folgt mir mal ich weiß
noch dass heute brauchen nur zwei sticks
holz und essenszeiten am anfang richtig
sehr kompakt wir suchen uns eine
natürliche höhle würde ich sagen
vor luca so ich weiß gar nicht ob ich
noch warten sollte bis wir unter der
erde sind mit deiner challenge was ist
der manager
doch sag mal sag mal wenn du mich schon
sich körperlich verausgaben lassen
willst dann würde ich sagen lieber luca
machst du mal zittern
warte bei mir ist es gerade viel zu laut
mit dem blitzen ich muss gleich überlegt
warum stellen
okay ich mache dir das mal zu ihm steht
auf der dann beschützt du mich aber kurz
ich fühle mich auch dabei was sind ja
noch was sit-ups halbzeit wobei kommen
folglich erst mal folgen erst mal wir
hatten wir haben erstmal ab in die höhe
ich mache sofort dahin letzte instanz
war schloss mit uns hier gegen 60
kräftig ich kann nicht mehr sprinten ich
auch nicht auch nicht gut finde
für die richtige art wir sind auf jeden
fall welche weil hier wurde etwas
abgebaut
ja da wurde holz abgebaut nein einem
baum doch okay du kannst für behörden zu
klären
hauptsache wir uns voll jung ja wir
brauchen noch irgendwie taktik jetzt mal
ja wir machen uns jetzt erstmal okay der
skelette die wir in uns töten
sicher wir können nicht also ich fand
sprinten wieder okay folgen jetzt
erstmal hier runter bringen ist hier ein
[Musik]
das ist so schade
europa will der hat extra ein konzert
sausen lassen dafür
okay ich habe er darüber gesetz das erst
mal nichts mache ist ja irgendwie die
zehn zieht ab aber ich darf ja ich muss
ja auf der taste bleiben wir auch was
für eine taste zum snacken halt ja eben
das habe ich nämlich auch gerade gedacht
okay ich mache jetzt dienstags ich will
mir nicht mehr sicher was it up sind
aber ich fühle mich mal dabei hier sehen
sie richtige setup italiener zeigt das
wunderbar vor die fersen sind am boden
die zehenspitzen sie darauf gestellt
jetzt kommen lukas setups wir sind so
das ist wahr was machen wir hier
uns liegen das mieten einer cottbus ok
hast du erst mal ein schwein stadt lucca
ich glaube uns da hat man ein bisschen
essen gebraten du machst hast du noch
holz marx ich bin ja ich bin es war zwar
nur zehnter ich bin wirklich fertig aber
ich hatte gerade echt ein schock meines
lebens war ich irgendwie einen namen
gesehen habe deswegen damit wir hier
nicht die ganze zeit mieten und solche
weicheier sind würde ich sagen max du
antwortest mir jetzt immer im chat
das heißt die ich irgendwas frage wenn
ich diese frage stelle antwortest du im
chat in den nächsten 60 sekunden max wie
geht's dir denn leute ihr müsst jetzt
mal auf den chat und nach könntest du
mir mal das wort vollidiot buchstabieren
[Musik]
wird dann hab ich weiß gar nicht was
machst du eigentlich gerade was ist das
beste team und war okay ist gestoppt das
ist eigentlich 60 sieg blieb eilig das
ist hier jeder liest das will dass mehr
leute es ist gerade so viele leute auf
dem server und mag es halt einfach in
den chat als ob dein ernst geht so dirr
vollidiot essen braten nine knights okay
du schreibst jetzt luca entschuldigt
einen wunderschönen teampartner max ich
habe ihnen gerade verleitet das zu
schreiben wenn die schule wäre würde ich
das schreiben ich würde mein
wunderschönen teampartner max ich habe
ihn dazu verleitet hast du schon ein
kurzer zwischenstand eben an dieser
stelle ich habe an dem ganzen video was
wir bis jetzt gesehen hab irgendwie
schon
in zwei stunden geschnitten und ich habe
jetzt nicht mehr so viel zeit und mit
erfolg wie gestern feiern waren ich
werde das ganze video ob jetzt ein
bisschen weniger schneiden also eher
musik im hintergrund und so ein paar
kleinigkeiten aber wie gefällt euch das
wenn ich war so ein bisschen so schneide
ich muss halt jede in games jede mehr
reinpacken deswegen kann ich das nicht
sagen einander schneiden die ich das
sonst bei gaming videos machen aber
vielleicht gefällt solcher trotzdem
und wenn ihr das wollt dass ich das
weiterhin bei den wahlen folgen so
machen mit den einblendungen und alles
ein bisschen ein bisschen schlecht
schneiden das auf jedermann vettel lag
da und jetzt gehts weiter mit war es ist
schreiben ging nicht mehr
also ich habe schreie gespräche hätten
abgebaut was soll das ja wir gehen
wieder in die natürlich behörde würde
ich also auch ich habe mich eingesetzt
okay es ist auf jeden fall schon viele
tot ich glaube es sind ja locker schon
sechs sieben leute gestorben oder so es
regnet dort das heißt klopps ja das
heißt allerdings gab's da vorne waren
relativ hohe oder ist ein krieg er
fordert eine natürliche höhle dass uns
da mal hingehen kurz und dabei die
gesagt essen mit einem essen mit dem
essen mitnehmen können wir erst am
anfang nicht genug von kriegen
ja ja alles gut
du magst wie stelle ich jetzt die
allerdings auf die plätze du musst
options sounds und dann irgendwie okay
ja ich möchte zu den lodges sounds
ob die musik und geräusche dann besser
einfach runter drehen
okay weil da habe ich jetzt gemacht wenn
mich das sorry leute daran habe ich
jetzt überhaupt nicht gedacht vorher
aber maxi rechts in münchen
ok sehr gut dann nehmen wir noch mit
protesten ja dieser schlag würde ich
sagen das ist echt krass dass wir noch
leben
vor allem ich würde mal behaupten
die ausgangslage ist nicht schlecht es
gibt halt immer in der ersten folge
schon irgendwelche kranken menschen die
ok hier ist kohle
hast du eine spitzhacke ist gut wie hast
du noch ein holz ja dann platzieren hat
er in den kräften table hatte ich mir
das ding zwar einfach ich halte in
derzeit ausschaut wer ist jetzt dran mit
wenn ich du wäre
ich bin dran und zwar sage ich direkt
wenn ich du wäre würde ich einfach mal
unsere koordinaten in den chat schreibt
aber stellen wir die kraft geworden war
du kannst du mich eigentlich komplett
verarschen helfer voll witzig war wissen
wir welche kohle abgebaut haben schreibt
mag es einfach mal unsere koordinaten
den chat weil das seine wenn ich du wäre
aufgabe
hey leute was haltet ihr eigentlich
davon dass wir dieses wenn ich du wäre
machen weil magst du nicht wir haben uns
wir haben uns einfach vorher gesagt ja
wir haben jetzt eine riesige chance das
ding zu gewinnen wir haben jetzt nicht
die ultra zeit das ganze über wochen
hinweg betrieben weil wir beide bisschen
umstellen lu gallen vaduz triesen
gegeben wo gott hast du angst ich hab da
noch cholera ist eine riesige
schlaglöcher was war noch nicht in die
warme wasser warum so brauchen wir
wasser sollen wir jetzt was her
kommt ernst mich verarschen
hier ist eisen maxi reisen ja meine
rheine rheine rheine und die kohle noch
mitbekommt leute jetzt haben leute unser
coach ok ab sofort liegen lukas liegt
nicht vergessen den gehofft hatte ich
halt nicht die ganze zeit nicht scheiße
das was uns sicher die dümmste wenn ich
tue ihre aufgabe aller zeiten für uns
vorsicht über uns ist aber nicht über
die abwandern sind jetzt sofort tot
hast du noch holz ich hab ja hier
hier geht mir bitte jemand im moment
noch mal eben constancy ab das
allerdings ganz gut ist dass ich auch
was machen kann der gleichzeitig seine
machen ja hier ist gestorben
und selbst jetzt bist du nämlich daran
opfer opfer richtig so
nein ich mich bei allen unbeliebt
jetzt schreibt du mal bitte inter leute
machen wurde oder dass der blitz ist das
erste blitzeis erschrecken mich doch
nicht so
der dawa grad irgendwas ohne spaß leute
ich könnt euch jetzt mal die zähne an
was der vorne gesehen habe
da war irgendwas max ich weiß nicht ob
sich gerade eingeblendet ich nachher
nicht richtig klappen
max berät da vorne hat uns reisen ja ok
lassen wir das mal anfangen rüstung zu
machen etwas hat keine kohle reingepackt
ich habe ja auch gerne gehabt gasthof
krone reingepackt hey lasst uns erst mal
ein schwert machen max ja wir gehen auf
jeden fall mal ein bisschen weiter rein
erstmal ein bisschen weiter rein in die
höhle ja nimmst du das da vorne wird
alles ich habe jetzt geholt
ok ich muss man eben die pole hier noch
aus so mag es bitte schreiben chat als
einfach war das achte rufen oh mein gott
bitte schreib in chat sowie dass luca
beleidigend wurde war seine aufgabe ist
auch so schreibt jetzt entscheidet opfer
richtig so beschreibt den chat sorgen
machen mir challenge
hey leute wir werden gehabt 20 text wir
sind bei waren fünf dabei half alter
hast du geschafft den table max und
schmeißt du scheiße es ist einfach so
eine schande dass wir es ist so eine
schande dass wir leben mit schwersten
hinter diesen schwer der serview von ihm
stehen und expert einfach so gestorben
nicht mal im kampf was die keine ahnung
haben wir noch mehr heißen wir lassen
uns direkt richtung machen
ich habe meinen mund genommen
haye wird übel heißt ich hätte nie
gedacht dass wir so lange leben ja man
das ist einfach die beim autobau was
sollen wir führen für rüstung style als
erstes machen
ok-chefin rüstungsteile machen
harnisch hat am meisten protection was
heißt harnisch brustpanzer ja dann
können wir aber nur ein machen ja egal
ich meine ich habe jetzt noch mehr
gefahren
wir sind aber auch demnächst einmal bei
15 minuten
das heißt wir werden dann aber
automatisch eingetreten
ja hast du noch essen eigentlich ja
essen gibt's ja welches also gebraten
ist das meine ich habe dir alles geben
von mir gerade hast du noch gewartet das
gemeint ist leider nicht die 15 minuten
sind sogar gleich vorbei glaube ich ein
paar sekunden
die schreiben wir das irgendwie zu bauen
guckt ja darüber werden wir werden den
kick ich glaube nicht
wir können ja mal ganz kurz schon ein
bisschen provisorisch machen
sicherheitshalber dass wir unbedingt
gefunden werden hier alles zugebaut
jeder und euch sagen erfolgreichen erste
folge oder wachsen immer alles raus aus
den öfen ein gegner ist zum nahm das
spiel zu verlassen
mister morris hier freut mich locker die
müssen in der nähe sein magst du das
reisen soll ich dir viel komfort
hinterher was vorsicht vorsicht
[Musik]
heute müssen wir uns in dem antrag
was aber komm komm komm zu mir kommt der
direkte weg
ja man noch reisen mitnehmen nimmst du
das noch eben mit ja hast du noch
irgendwelche rüstung wir machen kann ist
dass wir uns doch währenddessen die
krippen ich hab 77 reisen
okay ich habe gerade perfekt alter
granit erkennt man nicht wo wir uns hin
gebaut haben aber warum nicht wir nutzen
einfach die zeit und fahren ein bisschen
weiter ich würde sagen danke bis zu mord
an dieser stelle dich nicht schon mal
direkt gekillt ja ich glaube er hat in
europa zwei oder so hey ich kann egal
überhaupt nicht kommentieren ich total
komisch dass er bei uns ist ja es ist
richtig komisch du sagst du hast du
gerade hinter uns kann dies jetzt auch
gar nicht da kommen welche da kommen
welche luca vor sich leicht zurück ok
und unterband günter braun wunderbaren
mutter bahn kommen rein und die seite
gerne sagt luca ok ok kongo kommt jetzt
die alten blöcke hin
ja ich setze ich alles ok wat ich noch
mal runter noch mal runter okay das ist
uns unsere seite
alter was wieso sind sie dabei und sie
kann das sein
ich glaube jetzt jetzt dürften wir
entkommen sein bin ich ganz sicher ich
gehe noch mal runter
ich hoffe es nicht unter die arme
jetzt bist du um dich auch an euch
selber und ich warte ich wollte damit du
nicht aufpasst es liegen ja wir sollten
es sein
ich meine wir können uns ja nicht
aussagen von selbst folgen die noch mal
okay ich gerade die theorie blöcke
hintern setzen
ja mach das sind wir den weg in die
andere richtung auch so ein bisschen ja
irgendwas nicht auffällt also wie krank
ist das gerade was die sind immer noch
nah bei uns ja und kommt kommt zu mir
runter wo ich gerade bin
kotter luca ja eine spitzhacke ist
gleich weg geht nicht
[Musik]
ok und jetzt will ich sagen einfach
nebeneinander runter bauen okay wir
können nicht übernimmt direkt die
nächste folge aufpasst
wir müssen wir ganz überlegen wie kommt
immer noch nicht aus
wir können immer noch nicht nein wenn
ich springe sieht man dann trotzdem
einen namen
ja die wahl entweder weiß nix ist das
kein problem ich warte mal okay wir
machen jetzt genau nach jetzt folgendes
du brauchst dich neben mir einfach
gerade runter will man mag's ich muss
erst mal hatte ich habe keine spitzhacke
lerne ich bin ich bin runter runter wo
ich hingegangen bin fünfter und einfach
[Musik]
bist du runter pate noch nicht ich wurde
bei mir kommt auch noch ein gegner ist
okay ich bin vom server jetzt okay ich
bin runter junge junge jung war es das
wurde richtig krass doch zum ende gerade
ich kann's ich habe hier kann hier die
partikel zeigen man hat schon die blöcke
gesehen die abgebaut haben und wir haben
uns dadurch gerät ist dass wir so
unscheinbare blöcke wie reisen oder
sonst was genau machen hätten wir koppel
genommen wenn wir tot gewesen egal leute
das ist auf jeden fall unser konzept die
machen immer die ja immer verschiedene
challenges in jeder folge folge wasser
die wir nicht über ihre stellen wir
haben zwischendurch wirklich einmal
unsere koordinaten gezeigt jetzt
deswegen haben sie uns dann
wahrscheinlich auch zu boden oder
angesehen dass die in der nähe waren
also es war schon nervenkitzel pur
schaltet auf jeden fall wieder die
zweite folge eine nächste folge die
kommen nämlich morgen auf den kanälen
von max und mir da seht ihr dann ob die
uns nach scheunen ob es dann vielleicht
zu einem kampf kommt und sonst bewerten
nicht vergessen
und ich würde sagen die letzten worte
können ihren mac macht es gut und es
wird kraft werden ciao ciao